bonjour internet c'est m'inscris pour
brut aujourd'hui vous parler d'un
festival hip hop qui à vire au scandale
ça s'appelle vesti ville remise en
contexte quand tu vois ça tu dis un truc
de ouf
[Musique]
les villas de rêve
un line up de fou le tour en belgique
qu'est ce que tu dis direct les jv même
s'ils sont en belgique qui va mais petit
problème ça c'est pas exactement passé
comme prévu
ap on vient de loi vote mais steven ils
ont pas l'air très très content les
festivaliers brut a mené l'enquêté et
moi je vous racontais l'histoire
au départ le vch civile c'est ça d'abord
c'est sur instagram joue à des
informations qui tourne et j'entends pas
mal de damier qu'ils disent à tirer un
nouveau truc en belgique qui se veut
être mais guère ambitieux il ya vraiment
la volonté d'organiser un événement
musical en belgique un événement urbain
un peu s'en crée comme les tomorrowland
réduit pas pour lui
[Musique]
c'est un festival qui se sont créé très
très fort sur instagram notamment de
convoyer que c'était vraiment un public
assez jeune qui voulait toucher
j'ai trouvé ça très hype dans un certain
sens c'est une communication qu'on voit
très rarement quelque chose de très
imprécis sens avec le côté lifestyle
côté good music et tout ça
deux vidéos qui sont sortis sur youtube
où les présentateurs les organisateurs
se présente explique qu'elles aient
leurs idées l'organisateur a commencé à
se mettre en scène sur l'endroit du
festival avec notamment ben le
bourgmestre de lommel et l'avait
vraiment envie de montrer que c'était
quelque chose de vrai je pense que c'est
quelqu'un qui a un très très bon réseau
je me dis c'est cool on tombe sur une
communication qu'on n'a pas trop
l'habitude d'avoir en francophonie coup
sûr france et belgique
d'abord la fiche commencé avec car débit
et puis s'annonce de plus en plus de
grenon sur la fiche est en gros ils ont
aussi poussé les artistes à faire des
vidéos promotionnelles dans le cas lisez
oui effectivement on sera présent sur le
festival et donc ça évidemment ça donne
envie d'y aller
l'âge reste des vestiges festival où on
est donc sur un festival de folie avec
un line up de foucart diby et sa pro qui
il est mais qu'ils étaient à deux doigts
d'annoncer tupac andré et jusque là bas
tout va bien sauf que c'est une affiche
à plusieurs centaines de milliers
d'euros et on sait que c'est très
difficile d'organiser un festival comme
ça avec avec des noms aussi porteur donc
ils sont rendus compte aussi un certain
moment qu'ils avaient peut-être pas
assez de tickets vendus donc ils sont
dit on va augmenter la communication de
qu'à bruxelles il ya eu de plus en plus
n'affiche pour vesti ville de plus en
plus de panneaux il y en avait partout
on recevait aussi plein de pubs sur
instagram donc c'était très sponsorisés
et je pense qu'une de leurs erreurs par
contre ça a été de faire des tic est en
réduction c'est à dire qu'ils ont
commencé à faire des tickets à -10% par
exemple et sa part que c'est jamais très
un très très bon signal moi directement
j'ai envoyé un mail aux organisateurs
pour savoir un peu plus comme de quoi il
s'agit c'est en gros et ils m'ont
répondu par mail donc il y avait pas
moyen d'avoir une interview par
téléphone
ils m'ont expliqué que c'était un vrai
festival que tout allait bien se passer
je sais qu'ils étaient face à quelques
difficultés que j'entendais des des
problèmes de livraison des soucis ou où
il devrait pas forcément y en avoir en
fait il a tout d'un coup il commence à
avoir beaucoup de rumeurs des rumeurs
comme quoi ces artistes là n'allait pas
venir désertes des rumeurs comme quoi ça
allait être annulée de part et d'autre
il commençait à avoir des rumeurs mais
sans réel fondement juste masse et
marveaux j -jacques passe en belgique
dans le milieu on était tous un peu
sceptique en fait on connaissait pas les
organisateurs et que c'est un milieu qui
se connaît relativement bien et que
c'est un festival comme je design avec
une très très grosse affiche un très
gros line up on était sceptiques mais on
disait que ça allait le faire les jours
passent les organisateurs continuent de
communiquer sur l'événement
donc aucun problème enfin pour le moment
on est le vendredi 28 juin à lommel en
belgique
c'est le jour j et ça se passe comme ça
[Musique]
on arrive au backstage et là je vois pas
de sécurité la sécurité n'est pas
présente et on rentre comme ça dans les
backstage
je vais voir un gars que je que je
connaissais sur place qui me dit écoute
la sécurité ils doivent arriver on sait
pas ils sont pas la sécurité ont séparés
sont pas là lui comment c'est possible
je dis rien
il ya des artistes de demain qui vont
arriver des maîtres guînes c'est pas
logique ça
on est arrivé on a vu qu'il y avait pas
mal de personnes devant les grilles et
le festival aurait dû commencer une
depuis une heure donc on est allé devant
voir ce qui se passait et garcia civile
il ya des dizaines et des dizaines de
bénévoles qui est de l'organisation là
il y avait vraiment personne on est le
jour j et les plus ou moins 10 états à
partir du moment où les choses
commencent à s'emballer justement et on
voit qu'il ya quelque chose qui est en
train de se passer personne qui
attendait sous le soleil depuis plus de
cinq heures
on sentait que les festivaliers étaient
pas très content il était resté dans le
cagnard pendant des heures et des heures
sans eau et les portes ne sauverait pas
de l'événement
on voyait les messages de gens
mécontents sur twitter notamment sur
instagram boutique poteau
[Musique]
derrière qui annule festival
m
les festivaliers ont tous forcés ils
sont rentrés parce qu'elle est en colère
[Applaudissements]
j'attends pendant quatre heures pour la
file pendant très longtemps et tout d'un
coup leur annoncer bombe à des gars est
annulé pour aujourd'hui
les gens commencent à courir en plus
partout à monter sur certaines scènes et
certaines images assez marrant
d'ailleurs de gens quittent warcq sur la
mainstage on vient de loi il vient de
londres
on vient de swiss pour ceux qui viennent
de très très loin c'est quoi ça
[Musique]
voir t c et la ligne bleue
l'ampli pour les tracter ce torrent folk
rock et la xxxe de l'inao
d'après nom à savoir qu'ils ont mis rose
sans fil chez le preppy
et le mal
wes de thé asseoir mon stage
voyez toutes les installations les
scènes étaient toutes présentes c'est
une principale cliente est sur le coup
on n'a pas compris pourquoi
[Musique]
médina
on a senti que j'allais pas qu'on reste
parce que ça pouvait vite dégénéré puis
on était assez dégoûté et puis on les
gîtes partiel
c'est donc le maire de la ville de
lommel bobigny bob on va l'appeler bob
qui décide d'annuler le festival pour
des raisons de sécurité bon c'est le
moment où je fais une petite pause dans
l'histoire pour vous présenter qui sont
les organisateurs de ce festival il y a
radu taille sa petite amie amy nice
kovic sa soeur amira taille et charles
dennis chin un britannique chargé de
bouquets des artistes mais c'est sur le
néerlandais raboutet y que l'on va se
concentrer parce que bah c'est pas là
pour la fois qu'il fait cela en fait il
[Musique]
pas ou fait sur l'édition 2009 du
festival les investisseurs quand même
explications
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ensuite
très bonne question d'âge y répondre oui
déjà pour commencer il semblerait que
certains fournisseurs ont tout
simplement toujours pas été payés et du
côté des festivals il faut imaginer
qu'ils ont déboursé entre 80 et 400
euros pour les billets d'entrée
certains ont été remboursés mais c'est
pas le cas pour tout le monde pour
l'instant on n'a pas été pas été
remboursés du tout on a reçu plusieurs
mails des sociétés de vente de tickets
qui me disait que il avait payé les
billets aux organisateurs du festival à
voir le début et donc pour être
remboursé il fallait que ses
organisateurs leur rendent les billets
dont qu'ils étaient en train de les
attaquer en justice pour essayer de
récupérer l'argent et est là pour nous
le rendre à apple
[Musique]
pas mal de matos qui étaient volés
notamment pour une somme de trente mille
euros équivalente à 30000 euros
parce que les gardes de sécurité plus la
tête un peu le chaos pendant pendant
quelques heures 19 sections fft à ottawa
deux trois dix ou 100 oui a fait pousser
les gens qui organisent des festivals en
belgique sont des gens qui ont organisé
ces festivals depuis des dizaines
d'années qui sont très très ici
connaissent très bien là dessus donc se
lancer là dedans je pense que on peut se
lancer à petite échelle mais quand tu
commences à avoir trop gros dès le
départ c'est compliqué whiting des
travaux de taille son acolyte
britannique ainsi que sa soeur ont tous
les trois été placé en garde à vue mais
à ce jour ils ont tous été libérés
la police de lommel en belgique a
précisé à brut qu'une enquête était
toujours en cours
ils ont aussi passé un appel à témoin
pour que tous les fournisseurs qui n'ont
pas été payés se manifeste le parquet de
laon bourg en belgique a également
précisé à brut que l'organisation du
festival était poursuivi pour fraude
blanchiment d'argent et faux alors
amateurs à un hacker les deux ou aucun
des deux ça on ne sait pas vraiment ça
la justice belge de trancher en tout cas
ce qui est sûr c'est que les grands
perdants de cette histoire c'est les
fans de tupac